through Isaac we're here today to
celebrate the release of the complete
second season of Game of Thrones how
exciting is it really cool really cool
we've been sent a couple of DVDs and
been watching them all over all the new
DVD extras they're they're really really
good really good now for yourself your
character brand what was the highlight
of season 2 for you season 2 I think now
brands in season 2 brand get tanks on a
lot more responsibilities because a lot
of it all his family is sort of gone
they're in there in King's Landing or
they're doing something else and he's
Lord of Winterfell so I think I liked
being Prince of Winterfell and having my
own castle that was cool tell me about
some of the guys you work with the
courses Kristian Nairn and there we
spoke to him heard or recently tell us
about some the other characters well and
what they like to work with on sets well
I think one that definitely springs to
mind is Donald sump - blade maester
Luwin who sort of became a father figure
for bran in season 2 and he was just the
most fantastic actor he he layered his
voice in ways that you couldn't imagine
to do yourself and he I think I've
learned a lot from Donald in the way he
acted and he and he was lovely sauce it
was giving fun and obviously Christian
he's one of my absolute favorite always
having a laughing set always teasing
each other always always messing about
he's good
know you've grown a little bit since you
start the season he's got to carry
around on his back okay what was that
been like
that's been it's easy he's noticed the
change setting in a couple years that
we've been carrying Hodor
we look forward to saying interesting
television now what if you like you
actually McDonald though what have you
learnt from him you're taking through to
season three which of course we're all
looking forward to as well starting
first of April in the UK and 31st of
March in the u.s. yeah well I think bran
in in season two Donald sort of acts as
a leader in a way to brand and brand
follows him and in season three Brandon
sort of becoming a leader and he knows
where he wants to go and what he wants
to do so I think bran is he's picked up
on water on what maester Luwin taught
him and
he is almost becoming mr. Lewin maybe in
a vague sense so what were you most
excited about for season 3 what do you
think fans are going to be nice excited
about the season 3 well there are some
two two very popular new characters who
are coming in who who come in and sit in
book two in the books but they've spent
them - season three and they bring a
really interesting new aspect to the
whole brand storyline and that's what I
that's why I most enjoyed about season
Terry I think then you knew people more
to join the family then at the Game of
Thrones family exactly yeah the vast
huge family constantly branching out
every every day now what is it about
brand that you particularly enjoy
playing and how did you get into his
character but to be public I don't
really think that much about getting
into his character because it's
impossible to sort of imagine losing
your legs because it's such an alien
experience and lucky enough I haven't
really ever experienced something like
that but I've I've always sort of seen
some similarity similarities between me
and brandi's he seems like a decent kid
he me he seems like he he knows he knows
what he wants knows what he's doing and
I think he he knows how to get there and
I like to think of myself as that I hope
so what would you like to see in terms
of things progressing for the show in
terms of years to come I think it's
gonna just keep going going on what
would I like to see I'd like to see more
of tiering story well obviously see lots
of it I I want to follow turnstile and I
love doing he's going to give them what
is it about him that you like so much I
think it's just he brings this element
of comedy to this very serious dark
world where everyone's getting killed
and he just brings us in a little light
lighthearted bit - let's talk a little
bit about your costume in the locations
are you working because they're both
spectacular aren't they on the show so
great production values absolutely
phenomenal I mean Michelle who designs
the costumes she gets all these
influences from you go into a sort of
costume truck and he's got all these
these posters of different sort of
medieval things and everything ever and
what I think is fantastic is the way she
designs them
in as if they were medieval there are no
sort of velcro bits hidden underneath
they're all ties they're all this and
every morning have to go in you have to
turn them and it sort of really helped
to get into character because you're
going through what brand would have had
to go through and the locations i've
mystifies me how they find all of the
all of them and we for example in season
three there are some some words wearing
and they're just absolutely beautiful
the little sort of crevasses and trees
they find and I think I did a very good
job find them all if you had to live in
the real world of gang Rotarians if it
existed can you imagine how do you think
you would fare as brand oh I think I
think I'd be dead in five minutes I
don't think I don't think I'd be very
good I think is we will we're all sort
of so dependent on everything these days
I think if anything I spoke but there
were just beach but headed within five
minutes no iPhones or anything no yeah
yeah Puma Gameboy Google to find out
where am I at the very back yeah yeah
you have no idea yeah and that's quite
interesting too because bran would have
no idea really what's going on around
him and yeah when you watch the show you
think I he has absolutely no idea about
any of that anything else you'd like to
tell the fans out there kind of what's
happening what you enjoy about the show
I think I enjoy I couldn't put a bit I
don't like I love absolutely everything
about it I love the experience I love
meeting all the people I love doing the
acting it's just it's just living the
dream really is and why should you buy
the complete second season on DVD right
now oh well uh I might mention that
there is there's a beat boxing there's
there's a beat boxing theme tune by the
stark children real douche in the DVD
commentary which i think is a highlight
is duty I'm sure is it sounds like it
would be
yeah it was good fun it was kids but we
look forward to that thanks so much
you're talking to Zion lots of look the
future sees thank you very much thank
you
you